I'm not going to be honest.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Forith
Continuing
hadith number 10 in the first chapter.
The chapter regarding sincerity and
having a coherent
intention in all actions, all
statements, all internal
beliefs etc.
with regards to having an action or
doing something that a person intends to
draw closer to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
a person must in order for their action
their statement whatever it is that they
intend to draw them closer to Allah
they must have a coherent intention they
must have sincerity
in all acts of worship.
Continuing the narration of with regards
to the virtue and the merit that praying
in the masid holds over praying in one's
home or in his workplace or marketplace
as the prophet sallall.aii wasallam put
it.
He says
And so if a person perfects his
and then comes to the masid only
intending salah the only thing
motivating him to the masid propelling
him there is salah. This is his
intention
that
they will not take this person will not
take a single step except that
he will be raised a level by that step
and a sin be taken off of his weights
and scales
by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. And this
will continue until he enters the masid.
And once he enters the masid, he is
considered to be in salah as long as
salah is what is keeping him from
leaving.
As long as salah is what is keeping him
from leaving.
And the angels continue to make salah
upon each of you as long as he remains
in his place that he prayed in.
The angels say in their salah over the
human being, "Oh Allah,
have mercy upon him. Oh Allah, pardon
him. Oh Allah, forgive him."
This will continue
as long as he does not harm someone else
in any way.
As long as he does not break his wudoo.
As long as he does not break his woo.
With regards to the angels,
we mentioned yesterday that the word
which comes up a lot in the Quran is
plural for angels. Is usually translated
as angels which is correct.
But from a linguistic standpoint,
is plural for
it is plural for which originates from.
This word comes originally from the word
which is
which is a message and the meaning of
the word melik orch
is
it is a messenger someone who is bearing
a message.
This is referred to as a metal in the
Arab tongue
and because of the high
nature and the very pristine nature
because it's not just any messenger a
person could send you know a slave a
slave boy to tell someone or for
instance A woman could send her her son
to her husband to say it's time for
dinner. And this child would be
considered what? A rasool linguistically
is a messenger. He's bringing a message
to the father between the mother and the
father. However, you would never refer
to this child with this type of message
as a as a melik or a male, right? And
you would never refer to this message as
an al. Why? Because
al
they are the same thing in the sense
that they're both messages.
But al is a highlevel
very grave message. You wouldn't just
call anybody that. And you wouldn't just
refer to any message as that. This is a
message that is of very high and
important standing. It's kind of like
the word neb. Neba. What is a neb in the
Arabic language? It is news, right?
aba
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
but what's the difference between a and
a
prophets are referred to as
rightb
they are referred to as those who carry
the
they are not referred to asin
they are now referred to as those who
carry any type of message. No, a Neba is
an incredibly grave message of the
utmost of importance
and usually a neb is referring to future
events.
So
just any language there are a
number of words that may hold the same
general meaning but when we look at the
specifics of any two words they are
never exactly synonymous and they are
never exactly identical.
Now there's a lot of misunderstandings
with regards to the angels.
So for instance, many people
are are of the misconception
that the angels are
automatons that do not have free will.
Now you say, well human human beings in
jin, they have free will, but the angels
do not have free will. This is
incorrect. There's nothing in the Quran
and Sunnah ever mentioning something
that. The difference between the
human being and the angel is not free
will. Both creatures have free will and
have been endowed with free will by
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. The
difference between the human being and
the angel is the human being has a
nature to him. He has impulses. He has
desire to disobey Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala at times. Whereas an angel does
not have such impulses. An angel, the
angels do not have these this kind of
rebellious nature that they have to
fight with and grapple with. This is
what makes the human being different and
unique and special and sets him aside
from the angels. It's not the issue of
free will. It's the issue of it's the
issue of desire that a person the human
being has free will but they also have
desires that are illogical
that drive him and a person has to fight
with those desires. The angel does not
have this. Hence the angel does not
disobey Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. There
is nothing in the Quran and Sunnah that
would suggest that the angels do not
have free will.
And there are many evidences for this
but let's take one evidence from the
Quran. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala praises
the angels, right? He praises their
obedience specifically.
He says,
that the angels do not disobey Allah in
any command that he commands them with
and they do and carry out whatever Allah
commands them. So Allah praises their
obedience.
If a person does not have a choice
whether to obey or not,
would this be praiseworthy?
So the angels if they had no choice,
they don't have free will.
Why would Allah praise them for their
obedience? They It's not something by
choice. Praise is garnered for that
which a person chooses to be. You are
praised for that which you choose to be.
Let's say for instance a person doesn't
have a tongue,
right? And we say, "Man, this brother is
so of so few words. Doesn't talk at all.
You never hear anything from he never
backbites anybody.
How could this be praiseworthy?" This is
more along the lines of what? Mocking,
right? You would mock somebody in this
way. Why? Because they don't have a
choice. They can't speak. You only
praise someone for being stoic in a few
words if they don't have if they have
the ability to speak what they choose
not to. They choose to be stoic, right?
Or if a person for instance is blind,
you say you'll never catch this brother
looking at somebody. You'll never catch
them looking at something haram.
They they can't look at something haram
even if they wanted to. This is not
praiseworthy,
right? Praise comes from
when a person has a choice to be but
they choose they choose to be good over
bad. That's where praise comes from. So
the angels, they have free will, but
they carry out what Allah commands them
because they do not have those impulses,
those desires that they grapple with
that the human being does, which causes
the human being at times to disobey
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. The angels,
they make dua for the human being. This
type of angel makes dua for the person
as long as he is in his place that he
prayed in under two conditions. Number
one, that he does not harm.
Number two, that he does not break his
woo. These are the two conditions. does
not harm meaning harm anybody else
whether it be and and really the word
harm is kind of an incorrect translation
or it's a lacking translation.
The word wouldn't really be harm. It
would be annoyance because eda is an
annoyance that does not hurt another
person. annoyance such as something that
the person says or a foul smell or
you know foul breath or making their
salah because when they came in the
masid they happen to be by the door and
then when the salah is over they
continue sitting in front of the door
people can't get out right
this is a type of annoyance to others a
type of harm to others which will break
that dua that the angels are making.
We'll finish this up tomorrow morning.